le meilleur de ses fans guillon saison
suite au très beau portrait de michel
onfray sur michel drucker un autre
philosophe alain finkielkraut a tenu à
saluer notre mimi nationale
je tient effectivement
rendre hommage à michel drucker à une
époque où la télévision est devenue un
gigantesque peep show une glace sans
tain derrière laquelle le spectateur
observe sans être vu ou le buzz et la
mise à mort sont monnaie courante
la gentillesse et la bienveillance de
michel drucker sont profondément
salvatrice désire vous taisez vous je
voudrais terminer cette gentillesse que
d'aucuns qualifieront daube ces
curieuses nous lave en vérité des
attaques répétées de certains humoristes
qui n'ont de cesse pour exister que la
médisance la moquerie et la méchanceté
il est paradoxal de constater qu'il est
plus difficile de nos jours de dire à
quelqu'un je vous aime que de le
dézinguer je voudrais et j'en aurai
terminé taisez vous je voudrais dire et
ce n'est pas anodin que la personne qui
était le plus invitée par michel drucker
ces dernières années sur son canapé ce
n'est pas un être humain mais un canidé
un chien une réponse magnifique et
définitive s'il en était aux chacals au
loup au renard qui gangrènent
aujourd'hui la société du spectacle
je quitte cette émission
[Applaudissements]
le député républicain yves nicolin
accepte d'accueillir des migrants
uniquement s'ils sont chrétiens bah oui
c'est ça la solution pour que ça marche
il faut que les hommes politiques
accueil des migrants qui correspondent à
leurs idées rachida dati il faut des
migrants élégant louboutin hermès et qui
font pas chier qui pose pas de questions
fleur pellerin des migrants incultes qui
connaissent pas modiano sinon si l'on
avait perdues
marine le pen des migrants français de
souche
[Applaudissements]
deux fiches à la limite c'est quelqu'un
qui veut quitter neuilly pour saint
germain des prés elle l'accueille
mélenchon il veut des migrants d'accord
avec lui tu te tais tu fermes ta petite
bouche petite cervelle via bing cabinet
cabinet tu te tais tu te tête
dsk dsk veut pas de migrants il veut des
migrantes
[Applaudissements]
les migrants on tire à l'eso
oui mais pourquoi les migrantes
façon plus cool il est tendu
tient qu'une chambre qu'un lit camatte
la
halle peuple partage et
dénis ranque dit réalisons
elles ont été perdus
perdu en pleine mer
elles ont besoin d'un capitaine et biden
qui les aide qui les guide et qui les
soulagent
besoin
elles ont besoin d'un bar dame a dû
retirer du son à lui auxquel s'arrimer
s'abandonner se raccrocher
[Applaudissements]
santé la secrétaire d'état laurence
rossignol annonce la création d'un
village alzheimer pour 2018 pas de date
d'inauguration non non non ça sert à
rien
dans un village alzheimer l'inauguration
c'est tous les jours tous les jours le
patient découvre le village oh oh c'est
beau
un village alzheimer c'est hyper simple
une seule rue un seul restaurant avec le
même menu et un seul cinéma qui passent
toujours le même film jamais déficit
chaque semaine le maire envoient une
taxe d'habitation aux malades qui
renvoie un chèque
[Applaudissements]
quand les phrases qui ont marqué la
semaine les propos d' emmanuel macron
sur les fonctionnaires ont fait couler
beaucoup d'encre le comédien pierre
arditi a tenu à réagir
oui mais là là là pardon pardon c'est
celle assez lamentable c'est lamentable
ces données là c'est donner le bâton
pour se faire battre somme toute a alors
oui oui il dit effectivement je suis de
droite ce qui n'est pas honteux adepte
de droite moi je connais des gens très
bien qu'ils le sont de droite mais mes
macron macro ne peut pas dire les 35
heures c'est fini les fonctionnaires
sont des nantis est resté de gauche non
non non non bien que lui mitterrand et
kohl et mitterrand il avait des défauts
mais pas celui-là a pas facile à a c'est
comme un joueur de foot qui marquerait
contre son camp il ya un moment donné on
s'en sépare on le vire pas trop il faut
montrer qu'on en art à voilà à voile à
gouverner c'est choisir pierre mendès
france voilà ouais ouais c'est pas le
dernier des cons
[Musique]
je fais vraiment touché mouvements de la
wii wii a tout bon c'est en basse et
torres est embêtante et sérieuse dans la
serre gratuits en europe ça passerait
bien ça passe très bien
aucun doute cette chronique qui avec un
coup de chapeau à notre invité michel
onfray qui grâce à un seul tweet est
devenue dans la nuit du 13 au 14
novembre une star internationale
fabrice luchini qui affectionne
particulièrement la philosophie a
souhaité tout comme moi saluer
l'ascension fulgurante de michel onfray
[Applaudissements]
niche l onf reste ardèche là c'est
énorme t'imagines le gars d'origine
modeste naissance à caen fils d'ouvrier
agricole en 75 il travaille dans une
fromagerie l'enchaînent les petits
boulots il galère pas mal et peu à peu
il s'en sort pigiste à ouest-france prof
de philo ça commence à sourire le gai
brillant beau parleur on l'invite chez
ruquier quelques succès de librairie
l'art de jouir cosmos
politique du rebelle l'immense politique
urbaine
est là
la civic morbide et jenny vendredi 13
novembre paris est en feu 130 morts les
mômes fusillé entérale sont encore
tiennent aux frais truite en pleine nuit
la philosophie qu'on quarti quick tu
réfléchis après on freine balance la
cure est un truc du style fallait pas
les emmerder on n'a que ce qu'on mérite
qui sème le vent récolte la tempête
et là tout d'un coup c'est la gloire des
shs le met dans un clip le prof de
campath à l'international on ferait
beatles de la charia
tu le vois dans le clip habillés en noir
comme les autres mais comme il a des
lunettes tu sais que c'est lui l'intello
et frais star de dèche c'est énorme
non
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu